all right tony
yes tony uh where'd you grow up where
are you from originally uh
sarasota florida and tell me about your
family you have both your parents and
you're a kid
uh yes i did my parents were
based in the entertainment field my
father from poland
and my mother hungarian
father was with the ringling brothers
circus as a bear trainer
and a mother was an international model
and also produced uh circus's las vegas
style shows
and so i was raised in the entertainment
field 100 percent here in america and
overseas and how would you describe your
childhood
absolutely amazing when it came to
family
surroundings friends i had some issue
being gay and openly gay back in the 70s
that was a bit of a problem but
being in the entertainment field it's
much more accepting
so that that worked out
um i was just i was a content and happy
child i
can't say anything negative on my
childhood um
traveled a lot got the opportunity of
seeing
a lot of culture um just an amazing
upbringing
very worldly open to accepting everyone
religion creed race homosexuality
whatever we were open to everything in
our family and household
and that made quite a difference
occasional
issues that did happen in life
something that i had
suppressed for decades
was very interesting to come to
grasp and understanding of
was the fact that at 12 years old
i did experience molestation
from someone that the family knew
um that took me to a darker place at
that time
being gay thinking this was
okay because i looked
pre-teen i looked like a little girl i
acted like a little girl
and this person
took advantage of that
played up the whole oh little princess
type thing and it very
it took many years for me to i had
blocked it out
and
still don't remember a lot of the
details
but remember enough that
it changed me in a certain way to where
my caring and loving and the endearment
that i wanted to show others
was stronger because there was an
innocence that was taken at that time
and yet even growing up and still now
i'm
almost 50 years old i still have the
heart and the soul of a female so my
i care and love for everyone i
want to make everything better for
everybody
um i'm like a mother hen
a big brother a big sister you know a
mother godmother
um i try to be the real
in the circle i'm in now of sex
offenders
something i've noticed with most of them
is they don't have
support they don't have a family that's
loving them or embracing them
and sometimes family comes from
the family we make i've learned that in
the
gay world i guess i'll say because drag
queens do that
they have the houses where there's a
house mother and
all these gaybees as they will call them
and the house mother will take them
in under their wings and help show them
what life is about
on positive and show them positivities
because of the love and nurturing i had
growing up from
all my circus
family my aunts my circus uncles and
and showbiz family extended family that
still goes beyond anything i could
imagine on several continents
i still have that
that want and need to help others
the mistake i made and
i will not justify what i did
which i did touch a 12 year old child in
an
inappropriate manner
i will that will never be justified
i won't accept me it's because something
that happened to me in the past we make
our own decisions on what we're going to
do
but
there's a time that my heart will always
be broken on the fact that i hurt a
child and i affected them
what i went through when i was 12
was
devastating because there it was the
full gamut
of a sexual encounter um
i have no explanation as to what
transpired and why i i've been trying to
dig
deeply for many years on the night
that my offense took place
it was a matter of seconds it was not a
long term it was not
premeditated it was a short period of
time
literally seconds
even the mindset it was not there to
touch a child i like men i like hairy
men i have since i was young
this didn't fit my criteria of what my
my sexual interests were
regretful i'm devastated i hurt somebody
and for someone like me who wants to
only help others
and bring positivity
that it's taken a long time for me to
forgive myself and i'm still working on
that
in the entertainment field i've been
lucky i produced shows
i was an entertainer singer
i did a number of different characters
male and female
and costume designer choreographer
that world of the entertainment field
you it's easy to get lost in the magic
of all that
but the purpose of everything i've ever
tried to do was to
make people forget their troubles for a
while
and even if it's just for that hour and
a half or two hours they come to see the
performance
excuse me and now
i've had to find myself again because i
hurt
a child
because even even though the realities
it was it was
seconds that will last a lifetime
i know what happened to me was a short
period of time
i'm assuming but it did
it affected my outlook on
what love is um i'm a firm believer i
don't i've never believed in one night
stands i prefer
the idea of love compassion romance
very old school that way
but now
if i could apologize to him with all my
heart
with all of my heart i'm sorry
i hope with therapy you will be able to
get better
um i hope you will get past it
i am not a monster many of us
that live with the title of sex offender
we are not monsters
i don't believe any of us are but there
are some people that are truly ill
they have they cannot help what they do
and there are others that truly make
mistakes
would never offend again there are
others that
unfortunately are caught up in this
romeo juliet type of situation where
they were both underage when they
started a relationship and
then the boy or the girl became 18
and the other was still underage and
that becomes an issue
and for many parents
legal actions are then taken and there
are many people here in that situation
that live in this park
others that are set up on the sting
operations online
and if you're looking for something like
that online i
don't think you should that's the
negatives
um if you need therapy find it
but admit who you are and what your
situation is in my opinion
i deal with like i say play
the endearing mother hen here so i hear
a lot of the stories
and i love the fact that some are honest
enough to say
they need help and therapy is helping
them
when it's the right therapist and if
they're going
and working on the right issue not
everybody
has the same stamp on them as far as if
you're a sex offender you should not
have the same therapy
if you are a rapist or if you are a
molester or if you are
someone into pornography there are
different levels
and that's something so important for
people to understand
we're not all the same
but under all of it we're still human
and we all matter
what your biggest regrets
my biggest regret is
that when my personal life
and professional life were spiraling
in opposite and crazy directions
i did not stop myself
and just take a minute to
[Music]
put everything back in check
i allowed myself very briefly to go
to
a dark place and a place that's not a
norm
that's why i still i still fight this
within myself trying to understand
why i would allow
myself to go with there why i would
subject
someone i barely knew
to even a microsecond of
touching them inappropriately that
i will forever have a regret
i will try to learn to accept and
understand and i'm slowly working on
that but i still have
that's will always be a work in progress
but i think that's everyone
um but my regret is that i
i hurt a child unintentionally
and there was no satisfaction that's
there was no re there wasn't a reason
for me
to do this it wasn't
it wasn't my desire
an honest mistake i allowed my mind to
go to a bad a dark place
and
i put myself and and somebody
else in a very terrible position
nothing makes it okay
when i think back to what happened to me
and certain details
he tried to make it
affectionate and kind with me
and yet he was crossing the line
there's no even when we get
past that in our lives it's still in the
back of your mind
whether you look at it as a positive or
hurtful
whatever it's still there it's a memory
that doesn't leave you
and as a person who made that mistake
and hurt somebody
it's the same no matter how great
and how much help i want to give others
how much i want to do for others
and i've always been like that it's
nothing new that's just who
i've been i want to help and nurture
others
in the back of my mind i still i hurt
someone
do you feel like if what happened to you
as a child
at 12 had not happened this may have not
you have not done this you wouldn't have
done this
i've done i'm still up in the air on
that i don't know because i know some
people who've had absolutely no
molestation in their life and a fairly
good life
and had and offended and never had an
issue and
there was no basis they couldn't come up
with
um
is it possible yes
i haven't seen enough studies yet
nor have i been able to come up with the
uh answers on my own with that
i don't believe in placing blame
on others for one for one's actions
um i did that i made the mistake i
i'm not a huge drinker
i've gone through a couple of periods of
my life where i would drink alcohol
sometimes to excess
but
that it was a minute
amount of times in life and i think
in my particular situation that may have
played a role
because you your inhibitions i
i do believe even if even though it took
me very little to drink
to become intoxicated i do believe
that alcohol did play a role in that um
because i wasn't one to drink on a
regular basis
um even now i
don't drink i have had a couple of
drinks here and there
in the past two years um five years
really but
um
i don't i think that had to have played
a role
it was being in the dark place when your
world becomes
spiraling out of control personal life
mother passing away
um health issues around
yourself and other people and then you
allow yourself to
take a depressant which is alcohol it
makes you do things that you normally
wouldn't do
so i almost i want to say it's the
combination of
all those things that ball balled up
that made that night happen
and
that very possibly
what happened as a youngster see for me
it wasn't a traumatic
necessarily experience because it was i
was treated like the little princess
i was it was all beautiful
and this is how it was supposed to be
prince charming type of thing and
then the pain came and there was pain
and that i do remember
so i i can't say that they
go hand in hand for myself maybe for
others but for myself i don't think i
can say they go hand in hand
i do think that the combination of as i
say
sadness world spiraling out of control
and allowing myself to have alcohol
had to have played a role in that
because in any regular freedom of mind
i absolutely have no interest in
being with anyone that isn't hairy
and and a full full grown man
so in my particular case i
we find we try to make it
i try to find the ex you can't find
excuses for what you've done
you have to take responsibility but i
think a combination of all these things
together did lead to what happened in
my life and changed my life now forever
in some ways
spiritual ways and emotional ways
maybe a positive because i become more
understanding about things in the world
and people
in other ways it's a nightmare
how's your how has your family reacted
to it
um my father old school european
was very embracing
those that knew me and do know me
um were surprised and shocked
but they also
were understanding with they knew who i
was before all this that they knew the
caring and loving person
and the mistakes
that i've been lucky that most of my
friends and family have
overlooked the mistake
and even though they've accepted and
unders and
the love is still there it doesn't take
away it's still in my head um
how often does it come up in your how
often is it in your thoughts
i'm sorry how often do you uh revisit
it's actually i the it's the
what brought me here the actually being
uh
an offender affects me every day i think
about it daily
i pray on it um
and i try to continue learning
not just for myself but listening to
others and
reading doing as much research as i can
to understand
what makes this happen
not everyone has all the answers
for me it's something i do i deal with
every day i it breaks my heart
what's the most important lesson you've
learned
the most important lesson in all of this
when you feel your life spiraling out of
control
ask for help before
you take it to another level whether
it's
molestation or suicide
or driving under the influence
if you feel yourself spiraling out of
control
in any way shape or form and life is
more than you can handle
to me it's okay to ask for help
where too many people are expected in
the world to
not have problems to not
need help and i really believe that's
one of the biggest mistakes
now that you when you asked my biggest
mistake is i didn't ask for help before
it
got that far
there's nothing wrong in
admitting defeat
and sometimes world the world seems to
defeat us and the reality is when you
speak with somebody and you put the
words out there
you realize you're still more powerful
and you can conquer over everything
hmm
ask for help how long you've been in a
wheelchair
three and a half years i have
spinal and spinal issues and heart
issues
and number of other health issues that
are
altering my life and but i'm still here
and i stay strong i stay positive
um we're looking at surgeries coming
very soon
that i've had a heart surgery two months
ago
going for spinal surgery after another
heart surgery another heart surgery is
coming up
and then spinal surgery following that
and may not be able to make it help me
walk but
it'll take the pain away and
i just stay positive whether i'm six
foot four standing up
or four foot seven in a chair
i love everybody and i'm going to be a
cheerleader for anyone i can to help
them get through their problems
and be there for those that
need help and need to call out
all right tony thank you so much for
talking with me i enjoyed this very much
you